And now,
Great Moments in Unintended Consequences.
Part one: Black Liquor Bonanza.
The year: 2005.
The problem: Fossil fuel
consumption is too high
and biodiesel consumption is too low.
The solution: Create a generous
tax credit for companies
who blend fossil fuel with
environmentally-friendly biofuel.
Sounds like a great idea
with the best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
Turns out, paper companies were
already using a pure biofuel
known as black liquor,
which is extracted from wood
during the paper-making process.
It's a super convenient energy source
to run paper plants and mills.
But only blended fuels were
eligible for the tax credit,
so paper companies bought
fossil fuel they didn't need,
added it to the biofuel
they were already using,
and instantly qualified for very generous
blended alternative fuel credits.
Exactly the opposite of
the tax credit's intent,
but sometimes it all boils down to paper.
Part two: Billboard Bans.
The year: 1968.
The problem: Billboards cluttering
the scenic vistas of Vermont.
The solution: Ban billboards.
Sounds like a great idea
with the best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
As the billboards came down,
something new popped up.
A 12-foot gorilla holding up a Volkswagen,
a giant squirrel in a
striped bathing suit,
a 19-foot genie holding a carpet,
a veritable zoo of gargantuan
concrete sculptures,
all in the name of public art.
It might seem cute until
a development dispute
with a local bureaucracy results
in a 700-pound middle
finger on a 16-foot pole.
Enjoy the view, Vermont.
Part three: Equal Pay in Colorado.
The year: 2019.
The problem: The gender pay gap.
The solution: The Colorado
Equal Pay for Equal Work Act,
a bevy of new regulations on employers,
including a requirement that
all forms of compensation
be disclosed as part of every job listing
and a ban on asking job candidates
about their salary history.
Sounds like a great idea
with the best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
Not only does the law open up companies
to new legal liabilities
and administrative burdens,
it also hinders employer flexibility
when it comes to hiring.
As a result, some companies
like Samsung, Century 21,
Cigna, IBM, Nike, even PETA
have simply excluded Colorado
from their remote job listings.
Can't have a pay gap if
you don't have a paycheck.
Mission accomplished, Colorado.
Great moments in unintended consequences.
Good intentions, bad results.